[Music]
you know there are a few core principles
that we really should all agree on that
separates this country from a banana
republic or a despotic regime let's see
free and fair elections separation of
powers are great Constitution the best
ever given man and an impartial system
of justice it seems that every person is
innocent until they are proven guilty
sadly tonight we have many people in
this country on the Left they are
putting politics above what is a core
foundational principle now by now you
probably know the story judge Brett
Kavanaugh is facing one decades old
sexual misconduct allegation 36 years
ago Northern California psychology
professor professor Christine Ford now
though the alleged incident occurred
when they were both in high school in
1982 Ford made these accusations only
recently given few concrete details and
naming one witness now both the alleged
witness and Cavanaugh categorically have
now denied the charge law enforcement
they're not investigating the
decades-old charge and meanwhile judge
Cavanaugh his accuser professor Ford
have all been invited to appear rightly
before Congress on Monday is a very
important serious allegation both sides
should be given a serious opportunity to
speak and be heard Cavanaugh quickly
agreed to testify under oath
professor Ford well even though our
lawyer said she would appear in the
beginning well now that she's been given
an invitation numerous invitations she
has not accepted the invitation and we
just have a letter sent by her lawyer to
senator Grassley of the Senate Judiciary
Committee
she's now calling on the FBI to first
investigate her charges as a quote first
step now of course to get a full picture
we should also hear from others this is
36 years ago people that have known
Cavanaugh throughout these many years
former high school students former high
school girlfriends college girlfriends
they've all been outspoken about what
they say is impeccable character that he
has always been a gentleman 65 women
impressively have signed a letter
supporting the judge his former female
colleagues in the Bush White House they
too have spoken out in his behalf and
mothers of the girl he coaches in
basketball fellow college and law school
students
clerks of his and others that have
worked and known him over the last 36
years all speak well of his character
now tonight I can report that none of
this seems to interest the Democratic
Party clearly they are not interested in
hearing the full truth clearly they just
want to delay
sadly they want to disrupt and just blot
the Kavanagh nomination and even if that
means giving up the presumption of
innocence they want to impugn his
character no due process no trial
nothing you know believe me we've got
the tape take a look this woman is to be
believed and you can believe dr. Ford
this was attempted rape and this is a
woman who exhibits dr. Ford courage but
the classic signs of post-traumatic
stress I believe her listen first of all
anybody who comes forward at this point
to be prepared to testify in the United
States Senate against someone who is
being nominated to one of the most
powerful positions in the United States
government that takes an extraordinary
amount of courage not only do women like
dr. Ford who bravely comes forward need
to be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed let me just say
right at the outset I believe dr. Ford I
believe the survivor here there's every
reason to believe her she has come
forward courageously and bravely it's
another rush to judgment no presumption
of innocent mainstream media always
carrying the water for the Democratic
Party well they are toeing the party
line as per usual
let's take a look to come forward she
has no there's no enticement for her to
come forward by the end of the week if
judge Kavanagh decides he doesn't want
to go through this it isn't worth it he
doesn't want to maybe he can win but he
doesn't want an asterisk to mean it
wouldn't surprise me if he chose to
withdraw and chose to back down the
reality is I see it right now probably
this nomination is cooked and he doesn't
is he willing to accept that when the
time comes and withdraw it or not we
need to judge Brett Kavanaugh not just
on what he may or may not have done
how he treats a woman's pain and that is
something I'm even paying attention to
on Monday how does he respond to what is
happening whether or not he said he
agrees that this happened with her
does he take her pain seriously when you
look at all of this what do you see
selective moral outrage it's important
to remember some key details first
senator Feinstein and her fellow
Democrats they had this allegation for
several months
professor Ford issued a letter to
lawmakers back in July
now Feinstein when she met with
Cavanaugh privately for long periods of
time she never asked during any of these
private lengthy meetings anything about
this and by the way she didn't ask
Cavanaugh about the charge during the
public hearings that we all watched the
circuits that we watched she didn't
inform any of her Republican colleagues
about the charge until the 11th hour
when a confirmation vote was set and now
she even admitted today she can't say
everything being alleged is truthful a
quick moment of truth but she was
excoriated immediately thereafter watch
this I think it's really too bad that no
one called her or called her lawyer my
understanding is she got emails and this
is a woman and I really believe who's
been profoundly impacted by this now I
can't say everything streusel I don't
know but I do know that you had to
contact her lawyers well they did well
he checked in with Senator Grassley's
office
she was now been invited numerous times
to appear before the committee before
sending in this letter tonight now
Feinstein after being excoriated by the
base of her party she tried to walk back
those comments saying oh she believes
the press professor Ford is credible but
this is the opposite of what we believe
in this country the presumption of
innocence due diligence and frankly what
you're seeing and what you're observing
and what you're watching is dirty
political tricks at its worst we should
listen to all sides and then I trust the
American people will come to the truth I
trust senators will make the right
decision early today the president he
weighed in on these political tactics
is what he said he's an incredible
individual great intellect great judge
impeccable history in every way in every
way I feel so badly for him that he's
going through this to be honest with you
I feel so badly for him this is not a
man that deserves this this should have
been brought to the fore it should have
been brought up long ago and that's what
you have hearings for you don't wait
till the hearing is over and then all of
a sudden bring it up I feel that the
Republicans and I can speak for myself
we should go through a process because
they shouldn't even be a little doubt
they shouldn't be a doubt again they
knew what they were doing they should
have done this a long time ago three
months ago not now but they did it now
so I don't want to play into their hands
the president's right on every every
point he makes and brings us to the
second key detail you need to remember
any of the outrage that you're seeing
from Democrats over sexual misconduct
nobody else in the media will report
this this is what I mean by selective
moral outrage there was no outrage over
senator Ted Chappaquiddick Kennedy he
was the Lion of the Senate
remember he impugn the character of
Judge Robert Bork we had hurt last night
he successfully blocked Bork Supreme
Court nomination by slandering and
smearing him but this is a guy right
there at Ted Kennedy in 1969 he drove
his car off a bridge into shallow water
he left the scene of the crime and his
young female passenger not his wife died
in a submerged car he went home to sleep
that night he never called the
authorities until the following day he
told nobody that woman she hasn't named
Mary Jo Kopechne II could have been
saved senator Kennedy was revered by
Democrats as a hero there was no
Democratic outrage over look at even
Bill Clinton for example he was beloved
by many of the people still in the
Senate today despite of courses long
track record of known sexual misconduct
Monica Lewinsky Paula Jones Kathleen
Willey Juanita Broderick who accused him
of rape I interviewed her have you
interviewed all those women and that's
when he was the Attorney General of
Arkansas
still senator Feinstein Schumer dick
Durbin so many other Democrats
enthusiastically supported Clinton even
voted against his impeachment and then
there's current US Democratic senator
sherrod Brown his ex-wife accused him of
domestic abuse few years after what
they're claiming Senate on judge
Kavanagh did and even filed a
restraining order against him there's a
new political ad just out today look for
yourself now senator sherrod Brown is
facing his own me too movement from his
past these court records show sworn
evidence that Browns ex-wife accused him
of abusing her she said Brown assaulted
her a judge had to issue a restraining
order later she said Brown violated the
court order of pushing shoving and
bullying her Brown claims it's a family
matter but his ex-wife like other
victims has a right to be believed this
senator had to resign when evidence
emerged he mistreated women why is
Senator Brown different now senator
Brown and his ex-wife now get along and
she supports him politically well the
record speaks for itself that's the
record and still feinstein is apparently
unconcerned dover those charges we
reached out to her office today for
comments crickets and there's also DN
c-- deputy chairman this is now
currently happening keith ellison he's
running to be Minnesota's next Attorney
General Allison's ex-girlfriend recently
accused him of serious physical and
emotional abuse Ellison went on to win
his party's nomination for Minnesota
Attorney General yesterday she tweeted
the DNC refused to believe her
accusations and that they smeared
threatened and isolated her we reached
out to the DNC we reached out to Ellison
we still have yet to get a comment this
is the very same party that is now
trying to block Cavanaugh's confirmation
over decades-old misconduct charges from
nineteen eighty two people on the record
I believe her do you believe Keith
Ellison's girlfriend do you
did you believe Kathleen Willey and
Juanita Broderick this is the same party
of Harvey Weinstein and Anthony Weiner
and Eliot Spitzer and I can go on as
I've said before the charges are serious
and we need to hear from Cavanaugh is
accused of Professor Ford but when
Democrats tell you they want to get to
the
that they truly care about misconduct
allegations frankly I think we've just
proven they're simply lying selective
moral outrage rushing to judgment no
presumption of innocence the American
people are smart they see what's going
on every American deserves this
fundamental principle of presumption of
innocence you all deserve it and judge
Kavanagh deserves it and the woman
making the allegation deserves to be
heard these are serious allegations but
what you're seeing is a political tactic
that we have seen many times they did it
to Judge Bork they did it to judge
Clarence Thomas and now it's judge
Cavanaugh so you also have a right to be
skeptical and we're gonna have more on
this throughout the show but thanks to
President Trump we have important
developments on the deep state tonight
and we do have a disrupter in chief we
have somebody that's breaking dishes and
exposing the deep state and now that
house of cards is coming crumbling down
yesterday the White House announced the
president is declassifying P FISA
documents that should upend several key
corrupt former officials now we've
specifically talked about pages 10
through 12 17 through 34 of the June
2017 FISA application on Carter page all
FBI reports of Russian related
interviews with Bruce or all FBI reports
of interviews prepared in connection
with Carter page and FISA applications
well we're now awaiting the release of
these important documents which should
Rock the deep state to its core and by
the way that means information emails
text call me page struck Andrew McCabe
Bruce or Christopher Steele let's see it
all where is Spartacus when we need them
also tonight congressman Adam
well shifty Schiff he's worried that all
his lies about phony Russia collusion
will be exposed he's calling a
declassification of abuse of power well
that this will put the country at risk
and quote this is evidently of no
consequence of the president who cares
nothing about the country and everything
about is narrow self-interests know
you're gonna be exposed as a big huge
liar we've got all your interviews all
200,000 of them and meanwhile former CIA
director Brennan also freaking out
tonight feeling the heat actually called
on government
bureaucrats to defy the president's
orders obviously it was one a
constitution but we kind of knew that
before it didn't we take a look I think
Christopher Rea director of FBI and Dan
Coast rector of National Intelligence as
well as rod Rosen Stein who is
overseeing this investigation should
push back against any directive that is
going to have negative impact on our
capabilities as well as the
investigation so I think that should
continue to push push push
if mr. Trump in the White House does not
relent well then I think they have some
decisions to make whether or not they're
going to just not follow that direction
and be fired or to resign but if they
really believe that this is going to
have serious impact on our national
security law enforcement and judicial
process they have an obligation since
they took an oath of office to the
Constitution United States not to mr.
Trump to uphold their responsibilities
and their agency and departments
authorities with all due respect we
don't need lectures on the Constitution
from him and by the way he's feeling
safe and sound bashing the president
from his cozy little job on conspiracy
TV hate Trump MSNBC other officials
including him may be very worried
tonight specifically anybody that signed
off on those FISA applications against
Carter page Jim called me Sally AIT's
rod Rosenstein Andrew McCabe and the
rest of them and by the way McCabe
despite getting fired and there is
currently a grand jury convened at this
moment about him from the FBI waiting
the results of this criminal
investigation he's going to cash in on
his AMT Trump hatred he has a brand new
book deal and he'll need the money
because when the FISA documents are
officially released
we should come full circle on his abuse
of power as well as others and of course
without Donald Trump's win in 2016 we
would know nothing zero about the
widespread bureaucratic abuse of power
it's taken us almost two years to unpeel
every layer of this onion and the swamp
and the sewer a lot of work yet to be
done